DRAKE CARLSTON: Awesome.
Welcome, guys.
We're reviewing the
Tableau Concepts
section of the survival guide.
Super helpful if you
guys want to prepare
for the final or
the certification.
Let's start.
In Tableau, we have
dimensions and measures.
And if you're like me,
these are the first things
that come to mind when
I think of those words.
But that's not what
we're dealing with.
We're doing something
cooler, data.
I pulled this from--
everything I'm doing is coming
from the Tableau Help website,
which is a super helpful
resource for anything
Tableau related.
There's a ton of
documentation all by Tableau.
Super helpful.
This is straight from that.
So before we get into
dimensions and measures,
we need to understand that
Tableau identifies each field
as a dimension or measure.
So every field comes from a
column in your data source.
And you might have
covered this in class,
but that's why every year--
if you're working
on your project
and you add some data
source, and there
are like a million
things here and you
have to scroll
through them, that's
an example of wide data, which
is less optimized for Tableau.
So all of those columns are
being turned into fields.
And those fields
are either going
to be dimensions or measures.
So this is the main difference
between dimensions and measures.
Dimensions are qualitative, the
characteristics of the data,
while measures are
quantitative, like numbers.
So the way I remember it,
qualitative, qualities,
quantitative, quantity.
Yeah, that's really it.
So specifically, dimensions can
be any of these things or more.
Here are some examples
from the superstore data
set that's available on the
desktop version of Tableau.
So they categorize the data,
and then same with measures.
What's unique about
measures, though,
is they have aggregations
applied to them by default.
So measures, they're numbers.
So when we bring something out
into a visualization by default
Tableau, we want to do
something to those numbers,
so it's, I guess, smaller.
We will cover that more.
You might be asked
something like this,
if something has an
aggregation applied to it,
it's most likely a measure.
Moving on.
Did any of you guys talk
about this in class?
I'm not sure if this is
something we covered in class.
But like I mentioned
before, measures
have these aggregations
applied to them.
So there's actually a way
to turn that off in Tableau.
This is a classic example.
So we bring out--
let's say we want to look at the
relationship between discount
and profit.
So by default, it applies
the sum aggregation,
so there's just one point.
There are two ways we can
turn that aggregation off.
One is under analysis.
This is selected, aggregate
measures is selected by default.
If we turn that off--
let's flip the axis so
it's more meaningful--
if we turn that off, it
takes all those points
and breaks them out so
they're not aggregated.
Another way to do that
would be to come in here
and select dimension.
And that does the same thing.
But basically, a dimension
cannot have this aggregation
applied to it.
So there you go.
That's aggregation.
This is another screenshot
from Tableau Help.
Super helpful.
OK, so that's
dimensions and measures.
Now we have discrete
or continuous.
This is it.
So continuous means it's green
and forming an unbroken whole.
Discrete is blue with
individual and distinct.
Does this make sense?
When it's written like
this, it's easy to see,
but I always mix them up.
So continuous, like
if you're running
and you run a mile continuously,
there are no breaks.
But if you run a
discrete mile, which
is not something you
would say in English,
but there are these--
it's broken up.
One thing we want you
to understand is--
where is it?
We want you to understand how
discrete and continuous fields
are displayed.
Hey, Kauri, welcome in.
So by default, when you just
bring out a discrete field,
it's going to create a header.
And then with a continuous,
it's going to create an axis.
I'll show you.
That might be more helpful.
Let's just make a new one.
It's hard, just
based on that snip.
Here is a continuous field.
We bring it out, and
it creates an axis.
Meanwhile, if we
look at segment here,
it's going to
create this header.
And if we do it the other
way around, use the header
segment first, there you go.
Know that, that's on this.
So moving on.
There are four themes.
There are four things you want
to consider, dimension, measure,
discrete, continuous.
And a pill will fall into
one of these categories.
This is super helpful to know.
So the trick that I use to
remember is that anything can be
anything except a continuous
dimension cannot have a Boolean
or string value.
And that makes sense.
If something is a
Boolean, like true, false,
it can't be continuous.
And same with other words.
I made some examples of these.
These are not super
interpretable.
Well, some of them are.
You would never have a discrete
measure and a discrete dimension
compared like
this, but this just
helps you visualize
that any pill can
be one of these four things.
And this is what
they would look like.
So with a discrete dimension
and discrete measure,
you've got whatever this is.
But notice, sum of
profit as a discrete pill
is broken out into
these four sections.
And there's only a match
on every single year value.
Moving on.
Some of these make more sense.
So same here, notice we
have this sum of profit,
which is numbers, but we
have them as discrete fields.
So it's a discrete measure
with this continuous value--
with this continuous
dimension value.
So if we expand this
and get more detail,
you can kind of see
this continuous line.
Those two don't make
very much sense.
Next, we have a discrete
dimension and a continuous year.
So notice it's continuous
measure, so we have a line,
but we have this
discrete broken up year.
So when we expand
this, this line,
it's only continuous within each
quarter, and same for month.
And then this is an actually
interpretable graph.
This should be green.
There we go.
As we increase this
level of detail
on the dimension,
the date dimension,
we have this continuous line.
Then this is just a combination,
so you can see all of them
at the same time.
Awesome.
That's mostly it.
The main takeaway
here, in general, I
think this is a good rule,
and this is how I remember.
Blue pills break green
pills into smaller pieces.
Here, we have an
aggregated measure.
It is just one number, one bar.
If you bring--
I forget what I
had-- segment out,
it divides that
into smaller chunks
and gives you more detail.
That's pretty much all I have
to present that's meaningful.
Notice in here, there are these
videos for Tableau Concepts.
There are two videos.
Kaitlin Olson made them.
So I don't want to steal
the glory from her,
but these are helpful,
especially this one,
if you want to review more of
what different date values look
like, whether they're
discrete or continuous.
Also, these slides
will be available.
Watch this video.
Paul does a really good job.
It's like six
minutes, but he covers
everything I did super fast
and probably with more detail.
And then this is what I use.
This is Tableau.
Literally, anything
on the survival guide,
if you just copy and
paste it into Google,
the Tableau survival guide will
probably be the first thing
that you see.
And it's super, super
helpful documentation.
Do you guys have any questions?
Is there anything I can
answer any burning questions?
Super interesting stuff.